Selena Gomez's new man see the pics  can't keep my hands to myself Selena  Gomez can't keep her hands on Samuel  crossed et has exclusive new photos of  the pair Selena and Samuel a folding  hand Selena all dressed up in a sexy  little black number drink and phone in  one hand Samuel in the other the 23 year  old singer and fashion executive had  just grabbed dinner at the SLS Hotel in  Los Angeles but who is Samuel he and  Selena have been a rumored pair for a  few months now he graduated from New  York University last year and Samuel  also knows other famous faces he's been  spotted hanging with Bella Hadid for one  so what do you guys think of Selena and  Samuel are they dating let us know on  twitter using the hashtag ET now